hey everyone it's sarah with register
nurse Orion comm and in this video I'm
going to be going over how to auscultate
heart sounds what I'm going to be doing
is I'm going to show you how to listen
to heart sounds on a real person I'm
going to show you the anatomical site
how to identify s1 s2 talk about those
s3 s4 heart murmurs those extra sounds
you may hear the first let's covered the
basics okay why do we listen to heart
sounds what is the purpose well one
thing is we want to make sure the rhythm
is regular we want to count the rate but
we're also one of the big things is that
we're assessing how those heart valves
are closing because whenever you are
hearing s1 s2 those are valves valves
closing s1 are your tricuspid and mitral
valves closing and s2 is the sound of
your aortic and pulmonic valves closing
and while you're listening to heart
sounds you'll be trying to distinguish
am i hearing s1 s2 and then you're going
to be positioning the patient a little
bit different positions and going to be
listening for those extra heart sounds
like s3 s4 and heart murmurs so first
let's go over the anatomical sides here
in a second you're going to see what it
actually looks like whenever and you're
looking at the anatomical sites on the
chest but let me cover them real fast if
you want you can write this down so you
can remember it the key to help you
identify these anatomical sites is to
find the clavicle on the patient and
then go down and find the angle of Luis
the joint little area and the second rib
comes out from there and right below
that we're going to start on the right
side is intercostal space and right
there left I mean right of that border
is the aortic valve and the aortic valve
represents when it closes the sound of
s2 that in the pulmonic valve normally
close together so when they close
together they're similar looner valves
you will hear s2 then right over on the
left side in the same space
second intercostal space you will find
the pulmonic valve then down in the
third space you will find herbs point
and this is just an area where you're
separating the base from the apex it's
just the midway point between those two
areas and then you have the fourth
intercostal space which right next to
the border of that is the tricuspid
valve you'll find that on the left side
as well and the tricuspid and mitral
valves when they close together
simultaneously you will hear s1 and they
are filling the base then you go down a
little bit in the fifth intercostal
space but mid clavicular which is the
midway point of your clavicle and you
will find the mitral valve also called
bicuspid valve and these are your a do
ventricular valves your AV valves and
this is also where you will hear the
point of maximal impulse and also it's
important to know the bottom part of the
heart down in this area is that apex the
top part of this area is called the base
you'll want to remember that now let's
look and auscultate these areas and see
what they look like on a real person
okay first I want to start out just
showing you on the chest what is where
you're going to actually place your
chest piece whenever you're listening to
the heart what I like to do whenever I'm
first starting out either have the
patient set up or lie down and I like to
start and they or tick and work my way
down remember the mnemonic all patients
take medicine and herbs point is in
between the pulmonic and the tricuspid
and whenever your semilunar valves are
your aortic and pulmonic and when they
close you hear s2 and so you're going to
hear s2 the most at the base of the
heart and then whenever you're hearing
the tricuspid and mitral which are your
[ __ ] ventricular valves which are AV
valves you're hearing s1 whenever they
close so let's use a chest piece and
auscultate okay whenever I'm beginning
auscultation of the heart what I like to
do is remove the clothing and
like to have the patient set up you can
also have them lay down and I listen
with a diaphragm of my stethoscope first
and then I'll switch to the bell and
redo all the anatomical sites but I like
to listen a diaphragm because you can
hear s2 and s1 the best with this along
with your aortic and pulmonic
regurgitation murmurs so I start at
theoretic remember the mnemonic all
patients take medicine and what I'm
going to do is I'm listening for s1 and
s2 I'm distinguishing them and I'm also
listening for s1 splits or s2 splits and
this is just where the valves are not
closing at the same time so you may hear
a little bit of an extra noise so we're
going to store in the aortic over here
and what I'm hearing is love dub lub dub
and dub is louder because dub represents
s2 and in the base of the heart you're
going to hear s2 louder then how you
would hear it down there then I'm just
going to inch over here to the pulmonic
and I hear the same thing I don't know
in any splitting s1 s2 or closing at the
same time no extra heart sounds then I'm
going to inch down to herbs point this
is just the halfway point between the
base and the apex of the heart now I'm
going to inch down to the tricuspid and
this time I'm hearing lub dub and love
is louder because this is signifying
more where you're going to hear s1 and
love is represented by s1 and I hear
that louder in this area and then I'm
going to go over to the mitral area mid
clavicular and this hearing the same
thing loved a nice good rhythm and what
I want to do is I'm just going to switch
over to my Bell and I'm just going to
repeat and what I'm really paying
attention to is I'm listening for any
type of murmurs or those low pitched
sounds you really can't hear s3 and s4
that great in this position that's why I
hear in a second we're going to get on
our left
and you hear that best in the apex but
what I'm listening for is maybe any
murmurs blowing swishing noise and I'm
not hearing anything
now one thing you may find hard whenever
you are auscultate is the sink wishing
s1 from s2 and some tips to help you
with that
again s2 is going to be louder here at
the base and s1 is going to be louder
here at the apex so that can help you
with that or if you're still having
trouble you don't can't really
differentiate and you can feel on the
carotid artery and listen at the apex of
the heart and whenever you feel a
pulsation and you feel you hear that
noise you've identified s1 because the
carotid pulse ation and the sound
signify s1 or if you have a patient on a
bedside monitor you can look at your QRS
complex in the AR way the big spike
whenever you see that spike and you hear
the noise that is s1 so those are just
some little tips on how you can
differentiate between s1 and s2
now we've assist the patient onto their
left side and the whole purpose of doing
this is majority of your heart is on
your left side so whenever you turn them
have them go there it pushes the heart
over a little bit more just so you can
hear those anatomical sites a little bit
better and what we are interested in is
the apex of the heart and we're going to
be listening with the bell of our
stethoscope because we're listening for
low pitched noises and if the patient
was going to have an s3 s4 or a module
stenosis murmur this is where we have
most likely hear it so what we're going
to do is just find the midclavicular the
fifth intercostal space we're going to
just listen over there and we're
listening for s3 or s4 and murmurs
and s3 is hurt after s2 so again that's
why you have to distinguish between s1
and s2 and s3 is going to sound like a
love dub to love data because it's heard
after s2 s4 is going to be heard before
s1 and it's going to sound like this
Tull of de mm de Tunnel lubed up and a
murmur of course is just that blowing
swishing noise okay last what I like to
do is I like to have the patient set up
and lean forward and then have them
exhale and I'm going to listen for what
I'm looking for is murmurs aortic and
pulmonic murmurs and want to be
listening at the aortic and the pulmonic
sides with the diaphragm because it's
good at picking up those murmurs and
what's happening is that the chest the
heart behind the storm is just moving a
little bit forward so we can hear those
anatomical positions a little bit better
and I'm listening for like a blowing a
swishing noise and if one's present
you'll want to grade that and here on
your screen you'll see what the grading
scale is for that one a grade one is
hard to hear and it goes all the way up
to six and this is the loudest you could
literally lift your chest piece off the
patient's chest like this and you could
hear just the blowing and swishing noise
you could also fill in the chest a
thrill which is like a vibration on the
skin okay so that is how you auscultate
heart sounds now be sure to check out my
other video where I go in-depth about
these heart sounds I talk in great
detail about them a card should be
popping up so you can access that video
so you can familiarize yourself with
these heart sounds thank you so much for
watching and please consider subscribing
to this YouTube channel